c'est une manifestation en soutien au
gilet jaune incarcérées qui se déroule
aujourd'hui à paris entre novembre 2018
et novembre 2019 la répression à l'égard
du mouvement des gilet jaune a été très
importante
dix mille gardes à vue plus de 3000
condamnations dont quatre sont avec
incarcération immédiate sans possibilité
d'aménager la peine
je vous propose d'écouter ses gilet
jaune comme tous les samedis on est là à
manifester parce que monsieur macro ne
veut pas nous écouter
comme d'habitude ils préfèrent écouter
ce qui est bien les autres pays mais il
sait pas que il veut faire le superman
dans les autres pays mais c'est un petit
peu la mère de 6 en france on est là ça
fait deux ans qu'on se rebelle ça fait
deux ans qu'on crie nos revendications
et on n'est toujours pas entendu
aujourd'hui c'est spécial parce que on
va faire un soutien pour tous nos
prisonniers politiques qui ont été
incarcérés parce qu'ils avaient
manifesté on est là aussi parce que on
veut vivre dignement
voilà on veut vivre de notre travail
c'est toujours nous nous qui devons
mettre la main à la poche pourquoi nous
on est plus riche que moi je peux te
montrer mon contrat je suis à zéro là je
suis à 0 sur mon compte à tout le monde
moi j'ai des enfants j'ai 3 t de vie je
suis mamie de trois petites filles c'est
l'art à venir va le mieux payé les faits
je vais avoir bientôt 50 ans donc le
mien il est fait mais j'ai envie de
terminer ma vie correctement
le cortège est parti à 13h30 du 14e
arrondissement de paris son trajet
prendra fin dans le 9e arrondissement
place d'estienne d'orves à 18h les gilet
jaune qui appellent d'ores et déjà à une
manifestation massive le 12 septembre
prochain